une partie de skibus était à l'arrêt
aujourd'hui une cinquantaine de
chauffeurs de la Société des carperriers
a protesté devant les grilles de
l'entrepôt à trappe les employés qui
assurent 60 % du service des transports
du bassin cinquantinois demandent une
augmentation de salaire et une
amélioration de leurs condition de
travail aujourd'hui nous en sommes là
arrivés à ce à cette grève car c'est la
direction qu' l' a voulu nous avons
voulu à mainte reprise par de multiples
réunions entamer ce dialogue mais on
nous a fait comprendre clairement que il
y aurait aucune augmentation jusqu'en
2024 on demande 40 €
d'augmentation histoire de se mettre au
même niveau que les autres sociétés
environnantes on demande une
augmentation légitime suite à à 4 ans de
vache maigre aujourd'hui 92 % des
effectifs se sont mobilisés seulement
deux bu sur 10 ont circulés sur les
routes on s'excuse c'est une de la gène
occasionnée par cette grève mais bon
c'est une obligation on a pas d'autres
moyens de de de de communication
c'està-dire de de moyens d'agir donc que
c'est une grève bon c'est vrai que quand
les bus font grève on touche un maximum
de monde le trafic devrait être
fortement perturbé au minimum jusqu'à la
fin de la semaine vous avez affaire à
des gens très très
déterminés généralement les greffes chez
carperrier ça a duré 3 semaines c'est
historique chez nous c'est tout le temps
comme ça c'est quand il y a des greves
qui sont qui ont des revendications
valables ell durent longtemps c'est
c'est c'est c'est classique c'est normal
là aujourd'hui je pense que les
revendications sont légitimes une
réunion devrait être programmée dans les
prochains jours avec la direction les
car Perrier transporte quotidiennement
plus de 70000 voyageurs sollicité les
responsables de l'entreprise n'ont pas
souhaité
s'exprimer